Like a
boss.
I think she's coming around.
We went to the movies last
night and we saw a gravity,
we gotta find ourselves
a new kind of grabbing.
Um, and that was fucking
amazing. But you know what?
Sucks less fucking like the last five
times I've gone to go see a movie in Imax,
you know, neo, he sets it up and I
always say, look, this is Imax, right?
This is Imex. Yes. Yes. The Timex,
the time, right? There's like Imax.
And then there's Imax light
where it's the smaller screen.
The only fucking time I've ever gone
to a movie and I really saw it in Imax,
is when I saw the Heath Ledger Batman.
Now I'm always smiling.
Little fight.
I like that.
And that was one of those deals where I
couldn't see the cons head in front of
me and I felt like I was going to fall
off the edge of the earth. All right,
that's IMEX. What I saw last
night was not IMX. That was the,
uh,
that was the bud light of imax where it's,
it is a giant screen.
Yeah.
But like to me, Imax is all you can
see is the screen in front of you.
So fucking annoying. Those douche
bags down there on universal citywalk,
they got like three Imax. Once
they got the real one, you know,
the Alec Baldwin won and then they got
the Billy Baldwin and the fucking Stephen
Baldwin won. And if you're not
careful when you go down there,
they fucking pass you off.
Yeah, exactly. And both are really
rocking it at this point. Word happy.
Pleased to report the report is good.
So far so good.
You know, not saying that it's
not still a good experience.
Not saying that those aren't two fine
actors, but it's not Alec Patriotic.
It's not him.
He treated act patriot. I
love it. I love it. I love it.
All right, so last, so I was
a little disappointed with
that, but other than that,
it was fucking great.
Sandra Bullock killed it and um,
Jesus Christ. Um, and it's just,
just the thought of, I
think I could actually, uh,
I could be at peace floating away from
a station in dying that way and slowly
just having the oxygen go out is lonely,
is that would seem
just the fucking,
as long as I wasn't just twirling
through the air, doing somersaults,
then there's the earth. Then
there's this [inaudible] I,
I couldn't,
I could
fucking handle that if I was
just sitting there floating,
looking back at earth and
just sort of drifting away.
I think that that would be a
pretty fucking cool way to die.
What do you just gradually go to sleep?
I don't know.
If you breathe in and only carbon dioxide,
do you get like a headache?
I mean that that way.
It's such a fucking peaceful way to go.
If you're going to die
before your time. Okay. Okay.
What do you have fallen off
a building. Fox Plat, right?
Fucking fucking wind in your ears.
You're going down making no fucking
whatever noise you'd make on the way down.
Fuck that.
Get eaten like I think beyond,
what would you do?
Would you rather get burned to death?
Burned alive
or get eaten by a shark?
I'm eaten alive is fucking brutal.
Like if I had to get eaten alive,
I'm going with the big cat,
big cat in Africa.
It's fucking over after seeing
the lion tamer there. Um,
which really that's,
that's really just a title.
Nobody tames a fucking lion. You
basically, you had a good day. You're,
you're on a good run, but you know
what's going to happen eventually.
You know what I mean?
She charged me,
oftentimes I fishery the charter
charter right away. I guess the river,
a charge and sheer run.
And this is got to be a mind game because
I'm technically understand chance when
they're too vague. She's
still a baby. She's 225.
All right. You're not taming them. Okay.
You're trying to break their spirit,
but at the end of the day,
they're a fucking lion and that
the king of the beast. Okay.
Although some would say that the Bengal
tiger could kick the shit out of a lion.
I don't know about kick the shit out
of him, but uh, I dunno. But anyways,
just watching that are that Lion
Tamer in Vegas. Like when the,
when that thing grabbed him by the throat,
that dude went limp in like
fucking two seconds. It was like,
when you watch the UFC,
you know when someone gets choked out,
you get choked out real fucking
quick. So I don't have, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't want to get mauled. Like, I
wouldn't want to get attacked by a bear.
They're very sloppy, you know
what I mean? They're very like,
rip your face off and uh,
you know,
eat a little bit here and then come
back later after they took a nap kind of
shit. I like lions. Tigers,
they just get right to it.
They grab you by your fucking
throat in two seconds. That's it.
You're out it dead sober.
And then they, you know,
they have a meal,
I don't know. But anyways, when you look
at all those, and then the worst of all,
the getting eaten alive other
than a fucking Komodo Dragon,
which would basically bite ya and then
slowly follow you around for the next
three days is the poison takes over.
You know,
as you're laying there and the
things like two feet away, you know,
just staring at you.
It's Lizard Tongue flicking at the side
of your face but not eaten yet. You know,
that's fucking horrific.
Um,
plus you know, at Brett's towels
they just, they just don't,
they just don't have that.
There's, there's no emotion. Yeah,
the heartless.
They don't give a fuck mammals
and even like a lion or something,
they have some sort of understanding what
the fuck it is that doing. Just like,
you know, reptiles. I like the terminator.
[inaudible]
not even terminate a could talk.
I don't know what the fuck they are,
but they freak me out. I don't lie.
I don't like them. I really don't.
I respect mammals. I have, I,
I don't like reptiles there.
I made that statement and I'm sure I'm
going to get some backlash on that and
I'm prepared to go on CNN and defend
myself when I go on split screen with some
fucking lizard lover. But anyways,
so if you're floating through space,
like I could die like that.
I definitely could,
as long as I wasn't cold,
as long as that's suit held up
and I was just sort of floating,
that would kind of be the most,
uh,
that would be the ultimate premature
death. You're going to die in your 30s,
forties or whatever. I got, I still had
half my life ahead of me or whatever. Um,
as long as I wasn't tumbling,
if I was just sitting there floating,
looking back at the planet for
the last 20 years of my life,
and that's pretty fucking awesome.
You know,
me and lance bass up
there just hanging out.
You're going to make it
[inaudible]
can you imagine that? The first, you
know the first one, the first one, okay.
That they send up there with a bunch
of civilians. They was going to be,
somebody is going to freak the fuck out
that
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and I guarantee you they gonna they're
gonna, they're gonna have something,
some soda, some guy just runs down the
island, just like puts a Syringe, right?
D of fucking next seat on freak everybody
else out when it finally hits you that
you're leaving the planet
like God,
there is so many things that
scares the shit out of me.
But I gotta admit when George Clooney
just spun off into space and that fucking
movie, whatever the hell it was,
but he was so nonchalant about it.
Like I didn't care about his character.
Oh yeah, look at that.
There's a Serengeti. Oh, I
like it. This time of year
can float it off.
They made them to heroic.
I'm coming again.
Oh my God.
Hi Ryan.
We should see the sun on the Ganges.
It's amazing.
Alright.
Cause I don't give a fuck.
You know how much balls you
have as an astronaut and you do.
You have balls the size of my
fucking head, which is huge.
If you don't know who I am. Um, do
you never take a gander at it? Um,
I don't give a fuck who you are. You start
slipping off into fucking space. You'd,
I don't care how fucking bad as you are.
It is the second you lose your grip on
the space station and you start floating
off and the other people in there are
asleep or some shit, and you're just,
that's it. You're done. There's no
way. You just go like, well, you know,
I had a nice run. I guess I'm going
to set the record rebated space.
You know,
you're not going to say that
it is going to be at the line
and then it just fucking gone.
That is a fucking lonely
ass God damn death.
Okay.
Could I be saying more obvious shit?
Oh,
is it built to slip off into
the fucking space by yourself?
Now what happens?
Okay.
Hey,
remember the hole in the ozone layer?
How come they don't have a
fucking talk about that anymore?
Does that thing gonna do they fix it?
Oh my God.
Fuck this.
$25,000
tiger.
[inaudible] fuck it.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].